What do you think, David,
does it make sense to you?
>> So, to me this story does make sense.
I can imagine it as a story where
Ali and Sarah are co-workers and
Sarah has some kind of
authority over Ali.
Ali is looking around the store and
saying that there aren't that many
customers right now, so
maybe now is a good time take my lunch.
But if there's about to
be a rush of customers,
then now is not a good time because
leaves Sarah there by herself.
So Ali asks Sarah,
do you think there are going to be
many customers in the next half-hour?
Sarah knows that it's around lunch time
and Sarah recalls maybe that Ali had
commented about missing
breakfast this morning.
So, she can infer Ali's motivation
behind asking if there's going to
be many customers, and she says, kind
of anticipates the question he really
was asking and says,
yeah go ahead and take your lunch.
So, yeah, I can find a way for
this story to make sense,
even though it doesn't seem like a clear
connection between the two sentences.
>> That's good David.
Clearly you have an active imagination.
Notice how David introduced
lots of inferences here
which were not really part of the input.
How did he do it?
This is common sense reasoning.
How did he infer that it's probably
lunchtime and that Ali wants to have
lunch or that Sarah has some
kind of authority over Ali?
We have come across
stories like this earlier.
Here is another example.
Ashok wanted to become rich,
he got a gun.
Two sentences and you can, I'm sure,
understand immediately
what might be going on.
You may surmise that Ashok,
as a professor,
is unlikely to become rich, even if he
teaches this online Master's course.
On the other hand,
you may have some stereotypical story
about how some people become rich.
Well, there are banks, and
robbing a bank may require guns.
And so now you can relate Ashok getting
a gun to trying to become rich.
So you and I, as human beings,
have little difficulty in
understanding stories like this.
You might be given two
sentences like this and
we can connect them, causally connect
them, coherently connect them,
even if sometimes we use very
active imaginations to do so.
How can we do this conjoining of
sentences into a coherent story?
Put another way,
how can we make AI agent do it?
What kind of knowledge should the AI
agent have and what kind of inferences
must it make in order to be able
to connect these two sentences?